let me just write a general two by two
matrix a so
let's just say its elements are a
b
c and d
now from previous videos we have learned
how to find the inverse of our matrix a
the formula that we went over
the inverse of our matrix a is going to
be equal to
1 over the determinant of our matrix a
times what is often called the adjoint
of our matrix a and that's you are
swapping the a and the d so you have a d
here and an a here and you're making the
b and the c negative and this works for
a two by two when you do it when you go
to the three by three case it gets a
little bit more complicated so we're
going to have a negative b here and a
negative c here
or another way to think about it the
determinant of a 2 by 2 matrix is going
to be 1 over a d minus b c
a d
minus bc and then you multiply that
times
the add joint so that is fancy word
that's a fancy word for it so we have d
negative b
negative c
and a
so that is all review if it's not i
encourage you to review it in other
places on khan academy
but what we're going to ask ourselves in
this video is
is there a situation where a matrix is
not invertible so pause this video and
see if you can figure out a scenario or
a general set of scenarios where a
matrix is not going to be invertible
so one way to think about a matrix that
is not invertible is that for that
matrix we would somehow not be able to
make this calculation
now no matter what a b c and d are we
can always find an adjoint matrix
but what's a situation where 1 over the
determinant is we're not going to be
able to calculate it
well a situation where the determinant
the determinant of our matrix a is equal
to zero or i could write the determinant
of our matrix a is going to be equal to
zero in that situation we're not going
to be able to calculate one over the
determinant because that is undefined
and so we say
we say a
is not
invertible
if and only if i'll do this two-way
arrow right over here our determinant
for our matrix a is equal to zero
because if our determinant is equal to
zero we're going to have to divide by
zero when we find the inverse
now let's explore what that would look
like a little bit more if our
determinant is going to be equal to 0
that means that this expression right
over here is going to be equal to 0.
so that means that ad minus bc is equal
to 0 we can add bc to both sides that
means that a times d
is equal to b times c
and then we can algebraically manipulate
this a little bit more if we divided
both sides by b and d so let me just do
that if i divide both sides by b
and d
then the d's cancel out here and the b's
cancel out here so this could be a over
b is equal to c over d
so we have a situation where the you
could think of it as the ratio between a
and b is equivalent to the ratio between
c and e
you could also think about it the other
way you could divide let's start with
that original equation a d is equal to b
c
if you divided both sides by
c and d
so you divide both sides by c d
what you're going to be left with is
that a over c is going to be equal to b
over d
and so the ratio between a and c is
equal to the ratio between b and d so
all of those situations you are going to
have a non-invertible matrix because the
determinant is going to be equal to 0.
and so let's look at a few examples
i want you to tell me whether the
following matrices are invertible or not
so let's say i have the matrix 5
2.
is this an invertible matrix pause this
video and try to figure it out
so the determinant of this matrix
is going to be equal to 5 times 2 10
minus 3 times 1 minus 3 which is equal
to 7.
and since this is not equal to 0 we know
that this matrix is
invertible we can find an inverse
now what about this
matrix
so 10
and 250
and 500
is this matrix invertible
the determinant here
of 10 20 250
and 500
this is going to be equal to 10 times
500 which is 5000 minus 20 times 250
which is 5000 which is equal to zero and
once again if you wanted to find its
inverse you would take your add joint
matrix and multiply it times one over to
the terminate but one over zero is not
defined so this is not invertible